for one-dimensional collisions let's
talk about two objects one and object
two moving with velocity v1 and another
object v2 moving with velocity v2 let's
say they're moving on the ground now I'd
like to introduce the concept of
relative velocity concept that we
experience all the time in our lives but
let's see what it actually means so V
relative I'm going to define this to be
the velocity of one minus the velocity
of two now because of this minus sign
that seems a little bit of that abstract
but one typical example where we see
this all the time is four people
traveling on highways you might have two
cars one car overtaking the other car
but if you're sitting in car one it
looks like car two is going quite slow
so let's just take typical highway
example so you might have V one and
we'll give this some speed so we'll make
it 60 miles per hour
and we just call this a one dimensional
problem I had and V two notice we're not
speeding on a highway v2 is going at 50
miles per hour I had very slow and the
relative velocity v1 minus v2 so that's
what we're calling the relative that's
60 miles per hour minus 50 miles per
hour I had and that's just ten miles per
hour and that's what people experienced
when one car is approaching another car
if you're in car to car one seems like
it's coming at you at 10 miles per hour
this is what we mean by relative
velocity there's another important
example so that's example one the other
important example to look at example two
is when two objects are moving in
opposite directions so let's just write
here a let's write them terms of
components this time so we have V 1 X 1
and we have B 2 and let's make V 1 X
positive so object 1 is moving in
direction and let's write this one is
v2x
we don't have to call this initial we
just call it B 2x I hat and here v 2x is
equal to minus V 1 X so it's component
is negative and even though we drew an
arrow in this picture the picture is
still fine because if the component is
negative it means it's moving in the
opposite direction the key arrow is the
unit vector when we're writing
components and now the relative in this
case is V 1 X I hat minus V 2 X I hat
that's V 1 X I had - - so there's
another V 1 X I hat so the relative
speed velocity in this case has a
component that's twice the speed of the
one if two objects are moving together
at the same speed the relative velocity
the way we've defined it has twice the
magnitude of either velocity and this is
important example to consider in
collisions now
this relative velocity concept we'll see
will add a new way of thinking about
elastic collisions with no external
forces in one dimension